- As long as human beings
have been lending things
to other human beings,
there's always been the question
of how likely is that person
that I'm lending that thing to
going to give it back?
So there's always been this
question of credit worthiness.
Is this person a good credit risk?
If I lend them money, how
likely are they going to be
to pay me back?
Now people have always found ways
to come up with a solution here.
How much money do they have?
What kind of income do they have?
But in 1956, two gentlemen said,
"Hey, I think we can apply
the ideas of mathematics,
"the ideas of statistics,
"to actually become a
little bit more scientific
"about how credit worthy someone is."
and so these two gentlemen
started what is known
as the Fair Isaac Corporation.
Fair Isaac Corporation.
And when I first heard the name,
I assumed it was started by
a particularly fair Isaac,
or at least an Isaac who
thought that he was fair,
so much so that he named it fair Isaac,
but it's actually named
after the two founders,
Bill Fair, and Earl Isaac.
Actually the first one
was Fair, comma, Isaac,
and Corporation, then changed
to Fair Isaac Corporation.
And now it's often known as FICO.
Often known as FICO.
And what they came up with,
Bill Fair was an engineer,
Earl Isaac was a mathematician,
is an algorithm for computing
how credit worthy someone is.
So they came up with an algorithm,
and the algorithm has changed since 1956,
because clearly, technology has changed,
and our understanding of statistics,
and even the world itself
that we're trying to
understand has changed.
But they started focusing
on the problem of,
given some inputs, can I give a score
that can give you a sense of
someone's credit worthiness.
So they would take inputs,
they would take inputs like
total debt, total debt,
and actually not just total
debt, but available debt.
Total debt to how much credit
someone could get access to.
Things like payment history,
so have they paid all their debts on time?
Payment history.
And other things, like
length of credit history,
and the types of credit.
So length, length, and types of credit.
And other things like how many people
are inquiring about this person's credit,
and things like that.
And then they came up with a score.
And today, the modern FICO score,
and the FICO really is the, I would say,
the dominant type of credit score.
There are other types of algorithms
that people use,
but FICO is still the predominant one.
It will give you a score
that is between 300 and 850.
So 300 at the low end,
850 at the high end.
And the general view is, the general view,
and I actually talked to
some folks at some banks
to get their sense of things,
that anything between
780 and 850 is excellent.
You have excellent credit,
you are amongst the best credit risk.
You are viewed to be very likely
to pay off whatever loan
you're about to get.
Anything between 720 and 780
is considered still above average.
It's still considered very good.
And anything between 650, 650.
We'll do that a different color.
Anything between 650 and 720
is considered kind of middle,
or average, or just okay.
And anything less than 650 is not so good,
often referred to as sub-prime.
Prime would be an excellent credit risk,
or a good credit risk,
or an okay credit risk.
Sub-prime means okay, this
person's a little bit riskier
to lend money to.
So this is not so good.
Now, the question is,
who actually collects
all of this information
in order to apply the FICO algorithm?
And this is where credit
bureaus come into the picture.
So FICO, and it's a large
multi-billion dollar company now,
that does many, many, many things,
but it's most famous for
devising the FICO algorithm.
But the way that the credit
scores tend to be calculated
is by the credit bureaus.
So the credit bureaus are the folks
that will actually collect the data,
collect the data.
Your total debt, payment
history, and other things,
apply the FICO algorithm,
and then give you your
actual credit score.
And the three major credit bureaus
are TransUnion, TransUnion.
Experian, Experian, and Equifax.
So, if you were about
to lend someone money,
you could go to one of
these credit bureaus,
and you could do an inquiry
into their credit score.
And actually, you,
yourself, as an individual
can go and inquire about your credit score
with each of these bureaus.
And they offer different
types of algorithms,
but the FICO one is the most used one.
So you could get a FICO score
from each of these credit unions.
And the score might be
a little bit different,
because they all might have
slightly different data here.
But the way that it would generally work,
is if you were to go to your bank
and ask for a mortgage,
or go to a credit card company,
and ask for a credit card,
or get a car loan,
that entity, so let's say that
this is the bank right over here,
that might be interested
in lending you money,
they are going to go,
they are going to go to one
of these credit bureaus.
They're gonna go to one
of these credit bureaus,
and say, "Hey, give me this
person's credit score."
And so that credit bureau's
gonna look at all the data
that it has on that person,
put it into the FICO algorithm,
if the bank wants the FICO credit score,
and give a score right over here.
And if you have excellent credit,
then you might get a low interest rate,
or you might definitely get the loan.
If you have a good credit
score, you'll get the loan,
but it'll be a slightly
higher interest rate.
But if you have really bad credit,
your probably not going
to get the loan at all.
Now the last question
you're probably asking
is well, how do these credit
bureaus get the information?
How do they know how
much total debt I have,
and my payment history,
and the lengths and types
of credit that I have,
and the number of inquiries that come in.
Well, in exchange for lenders
being allowed to make these inquiries
and they usually pay the credit bureaus
to get the information,
they also agree to share this information.
So let's say this bank
does give you the loan,
they will tell the credit bureaus,
they agree to tell the credit bureaus
that they gave you that loan,
and they will also tell the credit bureau
about your payment history.
If you pay them all on time,
the credit bureaus will know about that,
and they'll be able to
input into your FICO score.
But if you don't pay it on time,
they will also know about that,
and that will also affect your FICO score.